and there are a lot of issues
implications lives have been lost people
have been murdered this is absolutely
tragic and devastating
and for the entire community right now
this will be deeply shocking so
obviously that's where the focus is
there will be a range of questions that
will inevitably be asked and i'll be
doing exactly the same for the
conversations and the discussions that
i'll be having with the chief constable
it seems really clear that this man had
linked to the
online subculture in sale do you think
that you and the police forces that you
are in charge of
are doing enough to combat online
extremism well the whole issue of online
activity and incitement and extremism is
an enormous issue and it's actually
something that the government is working
on already through legislation that is
forthcoming this autumn but i think
importantly we should also put this into
the context of what has happened
overnight we have to look at further
details the investigations by the police
will obviously give us more information
through the intelligence as to what has
happened and i am very clear about this
we will always learn lessons from
incidences terrible tragic events like
this particularly where there are key
factors online activity for example
you've already touched on another aspect
such as the firearm itself we need to
find out the facts let's establish the
facts behind this and of course we will
work to do everything to you know make
sure that if there are issues with the
online space i'll post this incident
that we will look to follow that out
and some of your critics might argue the
lack of a security minister at the
moment means that it's more difficult
for the government to hold on such
difficult development
well i would say that is absolutely not
the case i am the home secretary and i
oversee security issues and i've been
doing that throughout and that's not
nothing to do in relation to the point
that you've made i've been kept fully
updated and on all issues all incidences
including those types of issues and
incidences that don't even reach the
public awareness and consciousness i'm
fully sighted and fully aware of
everything that goes on